bonjour marie thérèse casimir yeux
bonjour monsieur wolton bonjour à tous
les martiniquais et surtout une pensée
spéciale pour les pointois parce que
vous êtes la maire de la commune de
bassecourt et merci d'être avec nous
pour évoquer cette lettre ouverte
adressée la semaine dernière à françois
hollande président de la république
lettre signée marie thérèse casimir us
mère de deux enfants et grand mère de
sept petits enfants dont un lycéen de 15
ans et cela a son importance la dame
casimir yeux tout à fait cela veut dire
que je n'échappe pas le statut de d'élus
n'entache en rien ma qualité de maire
avant tout de même de grand mère alors
c'est d'abord l'élu où la maman qui
écrit qu qui s'est adressé au président
de la république française pour lui
exprimer sa colère c'est la maman qui
profite de son statut d'élu pour
interpeller le président la république
dès lors que j'estime qu'il y a un
problème de sécurité publique qui est
posée alors ça vexe aspirez vous êtes en
colère est l'élément déclencheur si on
lit bien votre courrier si le meurtre de
yohan équinoxe en guadeloupe on le
rappelle pour son portable aux abords de
son lycée il était âgé d'une quinzaine
d'années tout à fait tout comme mon
petit fils et j'estime que je suis très
attaché à la notion symbolique
il estime qu' une école un collège mont
ici c'est un lieu public qui va
permettre justement aux anneaux jean est
ce que j'appelle une élévation à la fois
personnelle et professionnelle et des
lock on estime que à travers ce meurtre
ce symbolique il est attaqué il me faut
aller à telle société que vous décrivez
une société malade et vous demande un
contrat social aux couleurs des îles
tout à fait parce que on a le sentiment
de mon point de vue qu'il y à une
pratique un peu
discriminatoire et j'en veux pour preuve
cette adhésion à la fifa qui m'a fait
sourire
ce refus d'adhésion dumas la fifa la
ligue de la martinique de football qui
demande à dire à la fifa qui me fait
sourire parce que je crois que tout au
long de la vie de me dire martiniquaise
il y à cette pratique du ski ménard man
truck qui me gêne parce que je suis
convaincue qu' il y aurait un crime
perpétré dans les bouches du rhône ou à
marseille ou dans le
languedoc-roussillon qu'immédiatement
nourrir la présence de ce que j'appelle
l'autorité de l'état et ce n'est pas le
cas il ya une forme de mépris qui me
gêne d'autant que ce n'est pas la
première fois mais de la faire un
parallèle entre ce qui s'est passé avec
yoann équinoxe et puis la demande
d'adhésion de la martinique ont non non
non je parle uniquement des points de
vue discriminatoire j'estime qu'il y à
des pratiques qui sont alors que nous
sommes dans la république il y a
toujours des pratiques qui varie selon
pour des raisons que méconnu jusque là
alors madame casimir yeux sur ce que
vous demandez au contrat social aux
couleurs des îles
malgré l'aspect dramatique que vous
décrivez sa raison quand même peu doudou
east et tableaux du du douanier rousseau
de la compagnie créole est ce qu'on peut
dire ça du tout pas du tout j'estime
qu'il est risqué un grand temps si vous
voulez que qu'on s'interroge vraiment et
je pose la question est-ce que nous
sommes dans la france à la fois quand
ils vont pas le culte de l'échec ps que
nous sommes dans une france des
pratiques de l'inégalité
si ce sont des questions fondamentales
sociétal ce que vous voulez madame quasi
merlus ce que je souhaiterais surtout
j'avance ou si je met en avant la
situation des antilles ou donné j'étais
extrêmement peiné lors de visites en
france hexagonale de voir une espèce de
deux ans va dire un passage au creuset
de mes frères entier au blaney et qui va
jouer l'intro dans le métro dans son
domicile fixe et sans domicile fixe il a
jusqu'à toucher la femme antillaise qui
est au moins très un symbole la fin
matinée gaza toujours eu cette force
cette capacité à se dépasser et à
toujours masquer ses difficultés lorsque
je vois une femme martiniquaise dans le
métro doit en faire la manche
cela veut dire que ça ne va pas
cette situation met près ce que je
voudrais c'est à dire que lorsque je
parle de discrimination le mot n'est pas
trop fort en 1973 qui a eu le crash un
pétrolier la france a pu trouver le
moyen d'un tribut 1 et français de
l'hexagone ce qu'on appelle l'aide au
retour
je me demande pourquoi les martiniquais
dès lors qu'ils sont devenus des déchets
et n'aurait pas doit enfin les anti-ogm
ne nous est pas doit au bénéfice d'une
aide pour leur permettre de revenir chez
eux parce que j interrogé certains une
personne dans le métro dans une
situation difficile
comprenez bien qu'il ne suffit pas pour
moi de venir dénoncer et qui m'ont très
franchement dit je vais rentrer là mais
je ne peux pas j'ai dû me putsch
auparavant traité ue qu'est ce que tu
fais là je ne peux pas vous demander
même des lieux d'hébergement à
l'attention des des antillais guyanais
c'est du comité du communautarisme ça
dans un contexte très particulier mais
alors je pense que entre voir les
antilles en guyane et dans le métro ont
fait la manche et puis est passible de
toutes sortes surtout la femme d'actes
jeu mais vous avez quand même conscience
du contexte très particulier lequel nous
sommes aujourd'hui
mais bien sûr et je pense que vous avez
fait état de la date
l'envoi de ce courrier lorsque j'ai
entendu que lorsque je parle de la
france dany l'égalité lorsque j'entends
osé formation à l'immédiat vos collègues
de monsieur hollande aller visiter les
années à calais je me dis il faut
alerter sur cette proximité sur cette
mixité qu'on veut mais qui a qui pose un
problème
il ya un écart entre ce qu'on voudrait
la mixité telle qu'on vous la voudrait
la martinique telle qu'on avoue très peu
d'écart entre la mixité elle est vécue
alors il check des autorités d'idées en
plus haut lieu
échec également des politiques au niveau
le plus local qui soit par exemple en
tant que maire n'ont même pas du tout
parce que je vous parle on parle de ce
phénomène de violence de désoeuvrement
hockey qui ce qui me concerne notre
jeunesse de violence un peu qu'ils
étaient un petit peu jusque là rampante
qui devient galopante et c'est en ce
sens que cette violence est alarmante et
il faut toujours être force de
proposition et hamas mais nous sommes en
train de travailler pour créer les
assises de la genèse et pour comprendre
parce que il suffit pas de faire brûler
jeune mais il faut aussi boudé les
jeunes donc avec deux sociologues 2
imminent sociologue malick du entier
serge domi nous organisons à la fin ça
fait environ cinq mois que nous
travaillons sur ce projet et nous
rencontrer j'associe donc les jeunes des
communes voisines pour venir nous dire
qu'est ce que vous voulez commanderont
vous aidez votre look une conférence
séminaire résoudre à ce genre de 2,5
climatique s'est déjà fait cyclo club ça
nous permet ça au moins de connaître ça
ne s'est jamais fait dans le noir au
moins de connaître que ce que veulent
nous y sommes et puis d'une part c'est
notre manière aussi c'est de leur
permettre d'être acteur du développement
de leur territoire
c'est à dire qu'on va les intégrer dans
toutes les instances décisionnaires au
niveau de basse pointe campus manaudou
demain vous organiser la fête patronale
mais vous n'avez pas fait venir un des
grands acteurs dans la gestion
budgétaire les pour qu'ils sachent que
keller comment j'ai un budget hier que
ce n'est pas si évident que ça de fait
revenir kalach ou quelqu'un d'autre
qu'on est tenu par les est justement
j'estime que je suis dans la
transmission en tant qu'ennemi
apprendre à nos jeunes justement à
prendre le relais demain vous avez
demandé que le nouveau concept soit soit
crié qu'il faut pour vous parler d'une
nouvelle construction de la citoyenneté
basée sur la famille l'éducation la
religion et non l'asservissement de
l'autre par la terreur absolument je
pense que quand je cours aussi par
exemple de cette atmosphère délétère que
vous et que vous décrivez dans votre
courrier de contexte de tension de
réalité de guerre de pouvoir de toute
tentative noble de construction qui se
trouvent des nuits de sens pratique et
d'éthique à la limite on note on dirait
que vous êtes en train de décrire ce qui
se passe par exemple dans sept grandes
collectivités territoriales de
martinique en place depuis le mois de
janvier avec des élus qui montre
l'exemple
je n'ai pas la même vision que vous de
ce qui se passe et la collectivité
territoriale de martinique
je pense les faits tels qu'ils se sont
nés alors justement vous faites bien de
parler de ce concept d'asservissement de
l'autre jean la tireuse jeudi par un
dirigé dit simplement et vous avez tort
de faire une relation avec non parce que
je dis simplement moi martiniquaise qui
ne renie pas le contraire qui revendique
se doit la différence qui revendique ma
négritude qui revendique cette condition
jeudi en termes d'exemplarité
nous devrons en matinée qu'une vente
unique et 2 en termes d'exemplarité
apprendre à nous respecter par le
professionnalisme et lorsque je vois
qu'à chaque fois c'est le l'hexagonal
qui vient rappeler la règle lorsque
martiniquais doivent eux avoir un
éclairage veut qu'on lui fasse justice
et est obligé de sable et c est ça ce
que ça crie ça que simplement ce que je
alors que moi je me bats pour un concept
égalité des uns par rapport aux autres
on est entré simplement de rétablir
l'asservissement une suprématie de
l'hexagone par rapport aux monty
parce que je suis profondément convaincu
que les martiniquais ne sont pas aussi
incapable qu'on le dit et lorsque moi je
mets en avant ce concept égalité ce que
je revendique dans mon cou ya des
samsung
j'ai l'impression jour d'aujourd'hui que
je fais du dolce autisme
et ça le problème à casimir youssou est
candidate à la députation
vous allez écrire les droits et proposer
de nouvelles mais comprenez bien qu'il y
avait énormément de choses à faire
j'ai un contrat avec les pointois et par
conséquent pour l'instant je préfère
maintenir un engagement que j'ai pris
avec la population des basques
oui ou non seulement vous a répondu pas
encore merci d'avoir été avec nous
casimir youth maire de basse pointe et
mère indignée face à ce contexte bloqués
se trouve la jeunesse martiniquaise
bonne journée et demain l'invité de me
résultant sera rappel constant